20:16 was the outsiders election the
establishment versus the people and the
people have spoken thank you very much
sorry to keep you waiting complicated
business complicated thank you very much
I've just received a call from Secretary
Clinton
she congratulated us it's about us on
our victory and I congratulated her and
her family on a very very hard-fought
campaign I mean she she fought very hard
Donald Trump's rogue campaign has
baffled revolted and elated a divided
nation America has rejected Hillary
Clinton's pitch for continuity in favor
of Donald Trump's battle cry for change
now he insists he can be a unifier it's
time for America to bind the wounds of
division have to get together to all
Republicans and Democrats and
independents across this nation I say it
is time for us to come together as one
United people style I pledge to every
citizen of our land that I will be
President for all Americans and this is
so important to me
it's gonna be a beautiful thing every
single American will have the
opportunity to realize his or her
fullest potential they're forgotten men
and women of our country will be
forgotten no longer this election has
made history but not in the way people
expected the Republican candidate will
be the only president who has never held
public office or served in the military
and the only reality TV star to become
the leader of the free world says he's
ready to get started
I can only say that while the campaign
is over our work on this movement is now
really just beginning we're going to get
to work immediately for the American
people and we're going to be doing a job
that hopefully you will be so proud of
your president you'll be so proud again
it's my honor it was an amazing evening
it's been an amazing two-year period and
I love this country thank you thank you
very much
Manhattan is where it all began for
Donald Trump a year and a half ago it
started as a joke until his message
caught fire there's joy and disbelief in
this room the inconceivable is now a
reality Donald Trump will be the 45th
President of the United States Hillary
Clinton tried to convince the electorate
that the billionaire's crude often
hateful rhetoric on race gender and
immigration were at odds with core
American values but Trump's call to
drive out the corrupt political elite
punched through the silent majority
found its voice of course I know it in
my heart I knew it in my heart do you
think it did happen because America
wants change and they want to make
America great again and it's time to
bring something different no more status
quo we want to move forward and not
backward make America great again two
different Americas were on offer in this
election Donald Trump's has prevailed
Amanda Walker Sky News New York